is your foot all right I was thrilled
but at the same time I was kind of
confused I might do demo to take that
role I don't know so I actually asked my
kids do you think
Dad should your father should do a Star
War I mean do you like it man better or
or Star War better and they said Star
Wars of course so that probably that
changed my mind you know that's pretty
much it
[Music]
broke one
there is more than one sort of prison
Captain I sense that you carry yours
wherever you go one of the creative
conversation before I agreed to do it
and I said you know uh the role was a
little bit too cliche and how he carried
himself because in the beginning it was
the character was a little bit more
serious but then I said you know you
have enough of these kind of Asian
martial art Master right that's fine you
know if you want me to play that be that
Asian Master you want me to swing that
stick a little bit that's perfectly fine
but shouldn't he have a sense of humor
you know and he liked the idea and so
we're kind of adding lines and making
this character a little bit more funny
then I just kind of suggested it
wouldn't be even better if he can't see
where he can feel the force instead of
not really attached to it but then
somehow he have a grasp of that Universe
the one with the force
but one with the force that the forces
with me well in all my films and all the
characters that I've played in my entire
career I always emphasized on the
realism of the character no matter what
genre I do I always emphasize on
interpreting this character he has to be
grounded whilst you'll be off the wall
and no one understands where you're
coming from so that's how I approached
the whole character as not just the
action side so maybe that worked maybe
people
really came to liken this character so
much
[Music]
Once Upon A Time In China part two
as a professional artist you gotta do
your homework if you're Northern or
Southern
the accents the way you carry yourself
the way you look the gesture and all the
efficacy is very important if you really
want to play the character properly
accurately Once Upon A Time In China for
example that was during the Qing Dynasty
as in it
an actor who's uh I guess
specialize in action movies then you
have to kind of connect the two play
that character what type of style during
that time how are you gonna fight how do
you interpret that that's also takes a
lot of not only research but also a lot
of skill
[Music]
[Applause]
s getting into character not only as an
actor it's a more of a self-tuned in
mentally or physically but also the
environment helps you into that
character and that world so when you are
dressed in that wardrobes in that period
and you walk into the set and you
automatically put you in that
environment that helps you to get into
the setting I worked with jet three
times in my entire career I remember I
was in LA casting for Dragon
uh the Bruce Lee Story I didn't get that
role but I got a call from the producing
director and Jet Li himself said hey you
want to come back to Hong Kong and do
this so I went back and we were both
very young I think that we had that
little ego going on you know in on the
set so the choreographer was yumo ping
now yumo ping was the person who
discovered me 40 years ago very veteran
action director choreographer you know
he he did Kill Bills and Matrix and
Crouching Tiger and did all that action
well I want to make the long story short
the way we work in Hong Kong
for many many years is that with changes
the choreography as we go along so we
both very experienced obviously martial
art actor and well no we walked on a set
and we looked at the choreography we
started changing bits and peace in there
and it's kind of like happily sparring
and following the structure of the
choreography but then we went off and In
freestyle basically it's like rapping
contest you know what I'm saying it's
like every both of us just kind of went
on and we were going faster and faster
and faster where the camera couldn't
catch us we're going at it and the
director was like looking at the Monitor
and played back and said wow this is
great you know just keep it rolling keep
it rolling but yeah we had a really uh
interesting time because a lot of those
action choreography were improvised on
the set that's how we shot films back
back in the days now now is you know a
little bit more civilized you know we're
coming for the plan follow that plan and
we do this and do that but back in the
days there was Wild Wild West the way we
make action movies we walk on the set
and say oh this is the second this is
the building let's jump down from this
building let's crash this place you know
oh let's not shoot it this way I
remember there were many many movies is
where we didn't have a script we came in
and I was looking at the director and we
asked what what are the lines he said oh
I haven't figured out the lines yet
let's just say just say one two three
four seven six really and then we we
dump it later the most significant
experience working on
CE Upon a Time was that I had an injury
almost Blinded Me so what happened was
there was the shot where Jet Li was
wired up and we both had these pole
these are bamboo pole about this this
thick and they're quite heavy now if
they hit you in the head they'll knock
you out there was a move where he spun
around 360 degree he swings at me and I
block him after about 30 ticks he missed
instead of coming across and I'm
supposed to block it like this and it
comes across horizontally so it whacked
me right on my eyebrow right I mean I
got knocked back about eight feet five
seconds later I said wait drop my hands
and blood was spilling I kid you not it
was spilling like shower spray it was
like it was like this like in the move
like you built so I went to the
ambulance about six seven stitches six
stitches the day after they called me
and said are you okay can you come in
for a close-up on the right side I said
close up you can see my stitches no I'm
going to shoot you sideways so you can't
see the close-ups so what happened was
the day after I have patches on right
and he shot like close up on the other
side where you can't see the patches
that's how Wild it was
[Music]
The Hitman series
foreign
I was already a very successful action
director and and won quite a few Awards
in fact pretty much every movies that I
was doing was nominated and then ended
up winning the award so I was quite in
demand in the market as an action
director but like you said what's the
next level how am I going to elevate
myself oh then I have to really have
even better performance as an actor
because at the end of the day it's the
acting it's the drama right the story
right and as a result it was a very good
decision and you know I gave all the
credit to Mr Samuel Hong for the first
app Iman one two and then Iman 3-4 I
call him sifu the one that discovered me
you more ping he was responsible for
part three and four
when I found out I was going to make a
movie with Mike Tyson I was ecstatic I
was always been a fan of Mike Tyson
aside from Bruce Lee Mike Tyson was my
idol you know I was looking at Mike
Tyson wow you know I mean imitate him in
fact how he moves I said well can I use
something that Mike Tyson moves in my
movies so when I realized oh he's gonna
be in Ant-Man three so I was both
excited at the same time a little bit a
little bit nervous I was like you know
what if he actually knocked me out
knocking me out is fine but
I gotta finish the movie right it was
kind of that kind of excitement and and
that nervousness working with him
because I was such a fan and he's in
front of me and he's coming at me with
his famous left hook and I was like oh
Mike Tyson's coming over with a left
hook and I told you I'm paying I said
I'm not gonna be exactly like how we
shoot the traditional way of kung fu
movies where we always Dodge at a very
Split Second I'm gonna move when I feel
dangerous whether it is I'm not gonna
wait until his his fist is here you know
I want to move there was a shotway he he
came up with a left hook and it was
supposed to hit a big heavy bag so all
right ready close up you know the camera
rolling all right I felt that punch was
coming and I felt his forearm brushed my
hair
I said whoa but it was great fun working
with Mike and it was totally chill and
respectful I had more of a great time
working in that film talking to him then
that scene itself like we'll be between
shots and I would ask him questions I'm
a fan you know you got to remember so it
was a very memorable experience working
with Mike Tyson
it was an accident he was coming at me
with flurry of punches right and the
choreography was I was supposed to block
all his punches with Wing Chun
techniques now as the winching
techniques use your elbow sometimes the
elbow goes so I go at it maybe I have a
little power behind it and I just I
guess accidentally hit hit one of his
fingers like I didn't even know about he
didn't he didn't mention anything and
then next day he came in and he said oh
and he had he got banned something
wrapped around his fingers and we were
jokingly oh you know Donnie broke my
pinkies or whatever it was an accident
you know
get up
[Music]
everybody in the world some way or the
other is at least inspired by Bruce Lee
not solely on his physical Province but
his philosophy and how he saw things
it's kind of like a Muhammad Ali the way
he feels this is the future and I think
that's what I was drawn to him the most
with that elements we're no different
you know only the skin colors you know I
mean that kind of uh very liberal and
free thinking right the way he made
martial art movies was also impactful
and influence in all my films if you
look at all my films the temple the the
certain details it uh still have a lot
of Bruce Lee shadows in it right so but
of course at that time when I was young
watching Bruce Lee film
I never thought of how can an Asian
person be a lead in American movies and
English-speaking movies like I'm glad it
finally is here but it took a while it
took a lot of people like Bruce
to really kick down doors and making
that kind of difference pave the way for
someone like me who can have that kind
of opportunities to really
express myself
hero
[Music]
foreign foreign
experience as well I reunited with Jet
Li and I went to to Mainland China one
of those one of the set that they built
a courtyard of a temple we spent 21 days
shooting just two of us fighting 21 days
sometimes for Hollywood producers they
wouldn't understand why why doesn't why
do you take so many days to shoot action
scenes where because I shot some a
couple of American films where
everything's all the we have shot lists
and everything is on schedule I'll
finish the scene uh in two days or three
days you know getting the pieces getting
in coverage but that's not how we shoot
action over here we shoot action by each
shot and getting that shot to specific
lighting camera camera angles
choreography to the precisions to the
teeth so we spent 21 days sometimes
three four shots a day
everything was going smooth we united we
both wanted top Once Upon a Time part uh
part two that scene became a classic so
10 years later we want to do another
classic so
we both of us each shot we look back the
playback and look at each shot and said
oh you know wait a minute that that your
fingers is a little bit to the left
that's not precise enough all your your
eyes you know you're not looking at me
so we're both kind of going back and
forth trying to make the best piece a
lot right for each shot because I
remember there was one another
choreography where he was also wired up
with a sword now although these are prop
swords but they are still quite pointy
this whole shots was one take about 50
moves or something so at the end of the
50 moves maybe the 48 49 moves he
strikes downward his sword he went Boop
and I back up jet said Donny there's
blood spilling out of your face I said
really let me take a look he whacked me
on one side and 10 years later he
whacked me on the other side I started
laughing I said oh this is gonna be
great this movie is gonna make
so much money because the last time we
did this you know it was a huge box
success so you know you see in red
because in in Chinese red bag during
Chinese New Year we give each other red
bag so when you see blood it's like this
is gonna be a successful film six
stitches again two times both sides
close to my eyeballs I could have been
blind
[Music]
Wing Chun
[Applause]
let me begin with my mother being a
Pioneer especially during the 1970s she
opened a martial arts school in Boston
as a new immigrant at the time she was
able to break through barriers
of teaching all walks of different
race and culture so that made a lot of
impact on me to understanding the whole
woman empowering especially during back
in days in more of a male predominant
type of a world my mother is like four
feet eight or four by ten you know a
little woman so you have hundreds of
students like six foot five you know
following her and respecting her and
bowing down to her so you know that gave
me a different perspective so working
with Michelle that movie was about a
female lead in a martial art movie which
happened before but it's not not often I
was the supporting actor and just let
her do her job and and Let Her Shine
[Music]
I thought of the fire scene so I didn't
have any CGI there was no CGI scenes in
fact there was no CGI at all and there
was no not really a safety team or
whatsoever I said how do I love the
fight I really light up the fire I used
these kind of uh put some gasoline in
there I remember there was funny part
where I would let up the whole fire
except the shots and the fire would go
to go out so I have to call the people
on the side they said oh that that went
off you know pour some gasoline and then
burn up that fire it isn't like what's
today you can there's a there's a
pipeline there's you know all types of
modern technology where you just turn up
the buttons and the Fly goes up and or
you do it impose the CGI fire back in
the old old days we just have to do
whatever like if you want to crash that
window you crash the rear window you
jump off the building you jump off the
building you know so the same with these
fire props that I was doing literally
pour some gasoline and lift that fire
triple X return of Santa cage
I became pretty cool with the director
and he understand my background I
remember there was a scene where I was
fighting a bunch of henchmen inside an
airplane and I came up with a different
choreography to work with that camera
angle without telling them so a lot of
these choreographies that I did was
working with where they placed the
camera imagine the cameras over there oh
and I would look at the stimulographer
or the cameraman I said oh you know how
what's the size of the camera the lenses
right now look at the monitor oh he's
gonna have a medium shot or whatever
different lenses oh okay I I know how
you're gonna want to shoot this this
space do you want me to do this maybe
it's better like this maybe like this
I'll say oh that's pretty cool so start
changing all this stuff around and after
that scene and I told DJ the director I
said you know DJ listen how about give
me the footage let me edit this stuff
overnight and I'll give it to you
tomorrow if you don't like it throw it
away You're the directive with all the
respect so I went back used the computer
put them all the shots together and show
him my vision I said this is how I'm
gonna fight like the temple it's like
music right a couple of bars here and
then you know put it together and hey do
you like it and they loved it and what
you saw on the on the plane I edited
that scene
[Music]
Sackler
I wanted to make a movie that appears to
the whole world where even if you don't
understand
any culture of Chinese martial art
novels or jinyoung's particular you
still appreciate this movie so I came up
the story and then started bringing
these pieces together like how am I
going to do something that is different
from what's done in the past from
wardrobes again music and comes down to
the action now this can easily be over
the top where what's going on no one can
understand you know why is this guy's
flying around here and he doesn't come
down to the ground you know and then I
came out this concept of you know what
what is the most successful franchise of
these type of films right Marvel's
movies right X-Men's movies right we
believe in that world why do we believe
that what are the successful elements so
I use that as a study case to oh okay I
understand so basically this is my
version of the Chinese Marvels but of
course I don't have that kind of budget
you know I mean it's under a very string
of very tight budget I didn't have any
any money at all I just thought that
with my experience and my team was so
strong Hong Kong film Award winners
they're all like acclaimed
cinematographer editor wardrobes and art
directions so my whole entire cast from
actors to
behind the camera the crew they were
really supportive they really believe in
my vision they said you know Donnie we
trust you we believe you we want to go
on a journey with you even everybody's
getting cut no one is getting paid that
much honestly but we enjoyed it
everybody were in a ride together with
me and wanted to make make a difference
we wanted to to make something special
for the world a couple of elements is
really important in my movies number one
I say positive energy it's very
important to in my movies I don't like
to big movies where if there's a role
that is offered to me or price is
offered to me and it's against my morals
my principle of how I want to live my
life I don't care how much money they
give me I don't want to do it my movie
has to contain
some core values as a human being
righteousness family love that is really
important for me
as and also a very commercial movies I
like my movies to be entertaining
because at the end of the day what are
we making this for for yourself or for
the for the best and what I like to do
is make movies for everybody